[Aplausos]
rechazo por el maltrato a los haitianos
en texas la comunidad del país caribeño
residente en miami salió a las calles
para mostrar su indignación por el
maltrato de unos guardias fronterizos a
los migrantes que intentaban cruzar la
frontera en la ciudad del río texas
estas imágenes de la agencia reuters
grabadas el domingo 19 de septiembre
siguen causando una gran conmoción las
peticiones de los líderes comunitarios
que dicen sentirse traicionados y
avergonzados del gobierno byd e
impidieron detener de inmediato las
expulsiones aumentar la cuota de
refugiados haitianos y anular el título
42 una orden de emergencia sanitaria
implementada en la pandemia en marzo de
2020 que permite una deportación
acelerada con la excusa a resguardar la
seguridad nacional
mientras tanto en medio de apuros los
migrantes haitianos se encuentran alivio
en los gestos solidarios de los
mexicanos en ciudad acuña algunos han
recibido comida ropa y un lugar para
dormir
y pues vamos vamos a dar un poquito de
lo que nosotros tenemos para nuestros
hermanos haitianos algo muy similar
ocurre en el río grande en el lado
mexicano de la frontera con eeuu
voluntarios han improvisado un
campamento para suministrar implementos
de primera necesidad a los migrantes
ahora todos los mexicanos está pasando
la comida la ropa y ahora nosotros tiene
un lugar va poniendo bien los grupos
siempre de los migrantes alianza
américas y presentes o herejes afirman
que el trato de la administración bailén
a los migrantes haitianos y
centroamericanos muestra un sistema de
migración arraigado a la supremacía
blanca